Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now I'll eat my hat if this is going to be
two minutes, but I really hope you Fellow
Scholars are going to like this little discussion.
Neil DeGrasse Tyson described a cool thought
experiment in one of his talks. He mentioned
that the difference of the human and the monkey
DNA is really small, a one digit percentage.
For simplicity, let's say it is one percent.
For this one percent difference, there is
a huge difference in the intellect of humans
and apes.
The smartest chimpanzee you can imagine can
do tasks like clapping his hands to a given
simple rhythm, or strike a match. Compared
to the average chimpanzee, such an animal
would be an equivalent of Einstein or John
von Neumann. He can clap his hands. What is
that for humans? Children can do that! Even
before they start studying, they can effortlessly
do something that rivals the brightest minds
monkeys could ever produce.
Imagine if there were a species that is the
same 1% difference away from us, humans in
the same direction. What could they be capable of?
Their small children would be composing beautiful
symphonies, perfect harmonization for hundreds
of instruments, or they would be deriving
everything in the history of physics from
Newton's laws to quantum electrodynamics.
And their parents would be like: "oh, look
at what little Jimmy did, that's adorable!"
And they would put it on the fridge with a
magnet. Just like we do with the adorable
little scribbles of our children.
Just thinking about the possibilities gives
me chills. Now let's transition into neural
networks.
An artificial neural network is a crude approximation
of the human brain that we can simulate on
a computer to recognize images, paint in the
style of famous artists, or learn to play
video games and a number of different very useful things.
The number of connections that we can simulate
on the graphical card of our computer grows
closely to what's predicted in Moore's law,
which means that the computing capacity that
we have in our home computers doubles every
few years. It's pretty crazy if you think
about it, but most of you Fellow Scholars
have phones in your pockets that have more
computing capacity than NASA had to land on
the Moon.
As years go by, there will be more and more
connections in these artificial neural networks,
and they don't have to adhere to stringent
constraints like our brains do, such as fitting
into a human cranium. A computer can be the
size of a building, or even bigger. Computers
also transmit data with the speed of light,
which is way faster than the transfer capabilities
of the human brain.
Nick Bostrom asked a lot of leading AI researchers
on the speed of progress in this field, and
the conclusion of the study was basically
that the question is not can we achieve human-level
intelligence, but when we'll achieve it.
However, the number of connections is not
everything as an artificial neural network
is, by far not a 1:1 copy of the human brain.
We need something more than this.
A very promising possible next frontier to
conquer is called recursive self-improvement.
Recursive self-improvement means that we tell
the program to instead of work on an ordinary
task like do better image recognition, we
would order it to work on improving its own
intelligence. Ask the program itself to rewrite
its code to be more efficient and more general.
So we have a program with a ton of computational
resources working on getting smarter. And
as it suddenly gets just a bit smarter, we
then have a smarter machine that can again
be asked to improve its own intelligence,
but it is now more capable of doing that,
therefore if we do this many times, leaps
are going to get bigger and bigger as an intelligent
mind can do more to improve itself than an
insect can.
This way, we may end up with an intelligence
explosion, which means a possible exponential
increase in capabilities. And if this is the
case, talking about human-level intelligence
is completely irrelevant. During this process,
given enough resources, the system may go
from the intelligence of an insect to something
way beyond the capabilities of the most intelligent
person who ever lived, ...in about a second or less.
It could come up with way better solutions
in milliseconds than anything you've seen
on Two Minute Papers, and there's plenty of brilliant works out there.
And of course, it could also develop never
before seen superweapons to unleash an unprecedented
destruction on Earth. We wouldn't know if
it would do it, but it is capable of doing
that, which is quite alarming. I am not surprised
that Elon Musk compares creating an artificial
superintelligence to "summoning the demon",
and he offered 10 million dollars to research
a safe way to develop this technology. Which
is obviously not nearly enough, but it is
an excellent way to raise awareness.
Now, the classical argument on how to curb
such a superintelligence if one recognizes
that it is up to no good.
People say that, "well, I'll unplug it". The
problem is that people assume they can do
it. Or maybe lock it away from the internet.
We can lock it up in any way we can think
of, but, there's only so much we can do, because
as Neil DeGrasse Tyson argued, even the smartest
human who ever lived would be a blabbering,
drooling idiot compared to such an intelligence.
How easy is it for a grown adult to fool a
child? A piece of cake. The intelligence gap
between us and a superintelligence is more
than a thousand times that. It's even more
pathetic than a child or even a dog who tries
to fool us. We, humans can anticipate threats,
like wielding weapons or locking dangerous
animals into cages, and so can superintelligent
beings also anticipate our threats, only way
better.
It can trick you by pretending to be broken
and when the engineer goes there to fix the
code, the manipulation can begin,
It could communicate with gravitational waves
or any kind of thing that we cannot even fathom,
just as an ant has no idea about our radio
waves.
And we don't need to characterize superintelligent
beings as an adversary. The road to hell is
paved with good intentions. It may very well
be possible that we assign it a completely
benign task that anyone could agree with,
and it would end up in a disaster in a way
we cannot anticipate.
Imagine assigning it the task of the maximizing
the number of paperclips. Nick Bostrom argues
that it would at first, maybe create better
blueprints and factory lines. And after some
point, it may run out of resources on earth,
then in order to maximize the number of paperclips,
it would recognize that humans contain lots
of useful atoms, so eradicating humanity would
only be logical to maximize the number of
paperclips.
Think about an other task: creating the best
approximation of the number pi -
one can approximate it to the most decimals
by using more resources, to have more resources,
one builds more and bigger computers. At some
point, it runs out of space and eradicates
humans because they are in the way of creating
more computers.
Or, it may eradicate humans way before that
because it knows they are capable of shutting
you down, and if you get shut down, there's
going to be less digits or paperclips, so
again, it's only logical to kill them - the
task will be done, but no one will be there
anymore to say thank you.
It is a bit like a movie where there is an
intelligent car, and the driver is in a car
chase situation, shouting "we're too slow
and fuel is running out, please throw out
all excessive useless weights", and along
some empty bottles, the person would be subsequently
ejected from the vehicle.
We don't know what is going to be the next
invention of mankind, but we know what's going
to be the last one. Artificial superintelligence.
It has the potential to either eradicate humanity
or solve all of its problems. It is both the
deadliest weapon that will ever exist, and
the key to eternal life.
We need to be vigilant about the fact that
we have tons of money invested in artificial
intelligence research, but barely any to make
sure we're doing it in a controlled and ethical
way. This task needs some of the brightest
minds of our generation, and perhaps even
the next one.
And this needs to happen before we get there.
When we're there, it's already too late.
I highly recommend an absolutely fantastic
article on Wait But Why about this, or Nick
Bostrom's amazing book, Superintelligence.
There are tons of other reading materials
in the description box for the more curious
Fellow Scholars out there.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!